so ccsd students are not the only ones
that are going to be hopping on the
school bus this morning it's also the
first day for private schools and many
charter school students
bianca holman live this morning at
legacy traditional charter school
up in north las vegas bianca good
morning to you
[Music]
hey good morning john so yeah we're here
at legacy traditional school
they serve students k through eighth
grade and they've already got their sign
up
happy first day of school i know lots of
parents again preparing those book bags
and getting breakfast ready
it's going to be an exciting day today
get excited if you already aren't
i'm joined by a school leadership here
and uh natalie burgess so tell us
i know you all were able to have the
hybrid model last year you're adjusting
to it
what are some of those things that you
are doing to protect kids
right so we have some really strict
guidelines in terms of ensuring our
safety and our health on campus
our custodial crew have done a
fantastic job making sure that
everything is clean and ready to go
our teachers and students are constantly
washing hands wearing masks
and we have all those procedures in
place so that we can focus on school
yeah for sure
keeping our kids all sanitized down
sanitizer around
hand washing stations their mask and
everything while they're indoors
and also you know our value was hit hard
so a lot of parents struggling
financially
you all definitely are are here for your
family we are we really wanted to make
sure that we could do whatever we can
for them
this year all of our students have free
breakfast free lunch
last year we were able to send home food
for lunch and over the weekends
so whatever we could do to provide that
assistance if you've got an empty belly
you're not going to do much learning
but also i know you all brought back
extracurricular activities our kids need
them
absolutely we have a really strong music
program on our campuses
and we couldn't really do a lot of that
last year but we're excited to be able
to
in uh engage in all that again this year
have a big spring musical planned
so we're really excited to get back to
normal yeah yeah our kids work so hard
again with the technology i know the
teachers again trying to teach through a
computer screen trying to teach
music pe art through a computer screen
now they're back in person so
all great things happening here across
the valley private schools charter
schools
really welcoming our kids back with
opened arms let us send it back to you
guys in the studio
it's an exciting time for students
bianca thank you very much and for
teachers and for staff and for everybody
across the valley getting ready for a
big day thank you very much we'll catch
up with you later
this morning